- All right ya'll we're back,
and I'm hanging with Paula
Pell, Sara Bareilles,
Busy Phillipps, and
Renee Elise Goldsberry.
Give it up!
(audience cheering)
Together they play a girl
group in the new show
Girls5eva on peacock.
So it's time to find
out y'all who you'd be
in the girl group in real life.
So I'll give you one
question to each of you,
but then you all should answer
after that person answers.
Get it?
I think you get, yeah, I
think you follow. (chuckles)
All right, here we go.
Busy. Who in the group
trips walking out on stage?
- Well, our dear Paula Pell, and me,
but Paula you just knocked over a
- You just knocked over
two stands on the way out.
(laughing hysterically)
- [Paula] I'm I'm, I'm
not a graceful person.
I ride low, like fog.
I just kind of fill in the spaces
and if something's in the
way it's going down, so.
- She knows how to make an
entrance, that's what it is
- I ride low, like fog
- I'm very solid, I, I
hold my gravity very low.
- Yeah. So wait I'm Sarah
who do you think is the most,
you know, most likely to trip?
- Well, I don't know.
I, I guess I would agree that, you know,
I think we all have really
clumsy mo- know, I'm honest.
It's popped in my mind.
When, when Busy hit Renee in
the face with a salad bowl.
- What?!
- [Sara] Yes.
- Wait what'd you do?
- Oh my god, I almost forgot.
- Yeah, we were shooting
a scene in a closet
and there was a gag where
she was supposed to, you know
spill, toss the salad as it were.
(audience laughing)
And the next thing I
know, I was like, cut!
- Oh my gosh, okay, so then
- The shot of me talking
like this is still in it.
- But the best part is
like Renee keeps asking us,
like you guys, is it bad? Is it bad?
And it's like, her lip is
like four times the size.
And we're just like, no it's fine.
- There all lying
- No, no just keep acting
- I walked in after the
whole thing happened
and it was a very weird energy on the set.
Everyone was whispering.
She got a giant bag of ice
on her face and Busy was
kind of pacing around.
- See, this is what I imagined.
Girl groups are like.
(laughing)
- It was very funny.
- I know you can't laugh until later,
but then you laugh hysterically.
Like you've been holding it for a minute.
Cause you wanted to laugh before.
So Paula who in the group curses onstage?
- Well, I would say Busy and I
probably are the foulest
mouths of these four beauties.
I was on, when we did wine country.
When we went on the today show in
within 30 seconds, I said the S word.
- Oh, they, they frowned upon that,
I've slipped before.
- Yeah, I mean like immediately,
I think it was the first thing
I uttered and it was just one of those.
Like somebody said
something amazing and I went
(mouths the s word)
and I just said it.
And everyone looked at
me like I had, you know
- [Kelly] killed someone?
- Pooped in their purse.
(audience laughing)
And I was like, I am very sorry.
I guess I can't say that on
the Today show in the mornings
and my mother was watching.
So, but I think Busy and I are both pretty
unfiltered when it comes
to vocabulary like that
- I, I'm unfiltered too.
But do y'all feel like
you, well, first of all
I feel like I became unfiltered
when I was a waitress
because there were four letter words.
We're the only ones that felt good saying,
but I don't ever say it really in anger.
Mine's like, I just come in conversation.
I'm like
- I always, I usually say it either in
in joy or every so often,
if I'm really frustrated
about something, I'll
I'll use a good juicy word,
but a lot of times you just,
it's just becomes part of your vernacular
of just of joyful telling
a story or whatever.
- I get it. I get it. Busy you too,
You got a potty mouth?
- Yeah, same
You know, it's hard for me.
I just enjoy saying the words.
- I do too.
My mother can't stand the F word.
I know whatever, but it's sorry mom.
It's literally one of my
favorite words, you know?
And anyway, I think
(indistinct)
- [Kelly] You come from
a long line of what?
- I come from a long
line of women that curse.
And I'm kind of proud of that.
I'm kind of proud of it.
I think there's something beautiful
about a woman that's that doesn't like
feel like she has to censor her emotion
and how it comes out of her mouth.
I think that's very ladylike.
- I hope my mom, we're
going to keep this in.
So she hears that she, yeah
she didn't appreciate it as much as us.
So Renee, who's the leader of the group?
- Well, in terms of the gosh,
you know, there's a really
we're all very strong, but there's one
of us who is the ringleader,
especially when it comes
to doing something important
or amazing, amazing
or celebrating each other.
And that is Busy Phillips.
She is always like, you
know, 20 steps ahead.
She just like, we shot the show.
I've got me, we hit Christmas.
We hit, you know, new year's.
We hit a lot of birthdays and you know
way before anybody can think about it.
This girl has an idea to make some merch.
We have Girls5eva everything, just
because she's going to find
a way to give a present.
Would, that's been thought of.
Celebrate somebody amazing,
to everybody in the cast
and crew, you know, and
the worst part is she always
makes sure we all want to go
in on it for her, but she never
takes our money afterwards.
- No, we still don't know her Venmo.
So if anyone knows her Venmo
In, in the viewing audience
please send it to us because we,
- Listen Paula I get requests
every day from random people,
so I feel like you can probably find it.
(audience laughing)
- I'll always take the lead.
I'll always pick the gifts.
That's, I love doing it.
- I do too.
I think I'm that person
in my group. I love it.
I think mine comes from like,
I always felt bad when like
in childhood, like when
anybody felt left out
so I never wanted anybody
to not be included.
So I like try and go.
Now my friends will say, I
go way too, above and beyond.
And then I stress myself out doing it,
as I'm learning in therapy.
But, but yeah, but I think
but I think it's a really,
it's a nice thing though.
You're trying to make everybody feel
like welcome and a part of something.
And I love being a part of a team so.
Well we are out of time right now.
Thank you so much, ladies.
You can watch all episodes
of Girls5eva on peacock starting tomorrow.